YOU DON'T TREAT YOURSELF WITH
RESPECT.
>> Laura: OTHER COMMENTS WERE TO
OBSCENE TO EVEN GIVE YOU A
BLEEPED IN VERSION.
LET'S BRING IN MIKE HUCKABEE,
HOST OF HUCKABEE ON SATURDAY AND
SUNDAY AND FORMER OF THE GREAT
MANAGER WALKED ACROSS THE STREET
WITH A GROUP OF PEOPLE AND
FOLLOWED YOUR DAUGHTER'S FAMILY
TO ANOTHER RESTAURANT.
TARGETED WITH THESE WANTED
POSTERS WHICH INCITES PEOPLE TO
DO WHAT?
WHAT ARE YOU TELLING OTHER
PEOPLE TO DO TO HIM?
CITIZEN'S ARREST.
ANYTHING THAT VIOLATED THE LAW.
HE DIDN'T.
HE IS A POLICY GUY.
YOU LABELED HIM WELL A MOMENT
AGO.
HE IS A VERY NERDY POLICY GUY.
NOSE TO THE GRINDSTONE FELLOW.
WHEN THIS BECOMES PERSONNEL AND
PEOPLE TAKE IT AWAY FROM THE
PUBLIC VENUES OF A TOWN HALL OR
IT SO A PERSON LIKE PAM BONDI
THAT'S THE KIND OF THING WE SAW
AT LUNCH COUNTERS IN THE '60s.
I THOUGHT WE WERE NEVER GOING TO
SEE THAT AGAIN.
IT'S SAD.
>> Laura: SHE DIDN'T WANT TO
MAKE A BIG STINK, BUT DID SHE
SAY I SHOULD HAVE STAYED.
LIKE THE AFRICAN-AMERICAN MEN AT
STARBUCKS, THEY DECIDED TO COME.
GET THE POLICE AND THROW ME OUT.
DID SHE THINK THAT?
>> NO, I DON'T THINK SO.
MY DAUGHTER WAS NOT RAISEED TO
BE DISRUPTIVE.
SHE DOESN'T HAVE THIS ATTITUDE
THAT PEOPLE OWE HER SOMETHING.
SHE BELIEVES THAT IF THE LADY
I THINK HER ATTITUDE WAS I COULD
STAY AND MAKE A SCENE.
I COULD DEMAND THAT SHE SERVE
ME, BUT HOW DOES THAT SERVE A
GROWING LEVEL OF CIVILITY.
IT DOESN'T.
THE MANAGER MADE IT CLEAR SHE
WANTED HER TO EXIT THE
THAT'S THE WAY SOUTHERN WOMEN DO
THINGS.
THERE ARE PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY
WHO SEEMED TO HAVE BEEN RAISED
BY WOLVES RATHER THAN MOTHERS
AND FATHERS WHO TAUGHT THEM GOOD
MANNERS.
>> Laura: SARAH HAS A SECRET
SERVICE DETAIL NOW WITH HER.
IS SHE GOING TO BE DIABETES --
DINING OUT IN WASHINGTON SOON?
>> I CAN'T CONFIRM ABOUT THE
DETAILS.
I SAW IT ON TWITTER TONIGHT.
THE FIRST I HAD SEEN THAT.
2 THINGS, I AM GLAD.
I THINK SHE NEEDS IT IN LIGHT OF
PETER FONDA'S COMMENTS WHEN HE
SAID HE HOPED SOMEONE WOULD
BREAK INTO HER HOME AND KIDNAP
HER CHILDREN.
FONDA OUGHT TO BE IN JAIL
AS BEST SHE CAN.
THIS IS GIVING REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS A REAL MESSAGE
CLARITY.
THE WAY I SEE IT:
FOR REPUBLICANS EVERY DAY IS THE
4th OF JULY.
FOR DEMOCRATS EVERY DAY IS
HALLOWEEN.
AMERICA WILL GET TO DECIDE WHOSE
MESSAGE DO THEY WANT TO FOLLOW?
THROWING EGGS AT PEOPLE'S HOMES?